what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
i have seen wanda vision and
i absolutely loved it it was fantastic
now unfortunately i can't give you my
official review right now my embargo
lifts tomorrow so i will be posting
my official review for the one division
series tomorrow
huge thank you to disney and marvel for
sending me the pre-screening so i could
watch the one division series ahead of
time one division is coming out
at 12 01 am pacific time
thursday night slash friday morning so
i'm going to be having a watch party for
the one division series tomorrow night
at 11 30 p.m that's 30 minutes before
the series
airs so if you have disney plus and you
want to watch it alongside of other
people and see
live reactions be sure to join me here
tomorrow night again all i can say
about the series is that it's amazing i
truly
loved it and again big thank you to
marvel and disney for sending me the
pre-screening
don't forget to check my review on the
first two episodes tomorrow
morning and until then can't wait for
you guys to see it woof